how's it going red my name is beer and
all you have to do so yeah you might
already know who this guy is and if you
do then you'll get this but if you don't
I'm about to blow your mind
he's an international celebrity and a
multi-millionaire but even if you do
know and love pew ah you're probably
wondering how someone can make millions
of dollars doing yeah that I'm drew
Coolidge and I'm gonna explain to you
just exactly how hundreds of kids just
like cute cutey Felix his real name are
making millions from YouTube this is
hashtag news
despite his humble beginnings making
video game walkthroughs cutie-pie has
quickly become the biggest celebrity in
the world two kids under 18 when he was
featured on South Park as his real human
self Comedy Central promoted the episode
as the biggest celebrity cameo ever if
you find yourself shaking your head and
wondering what the world has come to
when some internet gamer is bigger than
other South Park cameos like George
Clooney Jena France doing a radio and
just remember he plays video games and
makes millions of dollars and it's lame
how he's got a point now there are a lot
of ways that someone like PewDiePie
makes money and we'll get to those in a
second but let's start with the revenue
streams that we all love and interact
with on a daily basis advertisements
just like in TV advertising is the basic
way you tubers make money from their
videos they can be banner ads on your
channel pre-roll ads that play before
the video starts or pop up once like
this fake one that you've been getting
pissed off trying to click out of you
can't it's fake I'm sorry don't worry I
got it
god I wish they all did that now
originally YouTube wasn't meant to be a
money tree I think it was originally
just for sharing videos of elephants no
that's pretty much all since they kicked
off their partner program in 2007 anyone
can become a content partner
that means YouTube runs ads on your
channel and you take home a percentage
of the profit how much your channels ads
are worth is calculated as a CPM or cost
per thousand impressions but what you
care about is rpm revenue per thousand
views because that's what you actually
get to take home at the end of the day
kind of typical rpm might be one dollar
per 1000 views so if your video got 1
million views using the formula we
established let's see that would be
carry the one one thousand dollars and
the end of the world is at December
twenty first two thousand eighty one
wait what equation was I doing any hope
now a CPM and RPM vary depending on the
channels audience or target demo as I
show off an ad executive might say and
the kind of audience you attract depends
on the content you make obviously check
out DC toy collector hey this is the cab
who made four point nine million dollars
last year by unwrapping and assembling
toys that's four point nine million
dollars in real non monopoly money
making her the highest earning YouTube
channel of 2014 how does she make it
rain so hard because people watching her
video
are an incredibly much audience that are
highly likely to consider buying these
toys and advertisers are understandably
desperate to place their ads in these
videos thus they have a way higher CPM
and this video is about a dentistry toy
and it has 87 million views have you
guys seen my toy robot it can you know I
gotta hide the body I gotta hide the
body anywho where's my toy robot moving
on while advertising may technically be
the most common way a YouTube creator
can make money with Google taking up to
a whopping 45% of that revenue most of
the big dogs of YouTube have found other
ways to make some cash I'll show you a
good time baby okay get it what well
sort of once you build a large enough
following of dedicated fans you can take
your bro army to the glorious world of a
brand deals brand deals our product
integrations where external advertisers
write fat checks to get popular
youtubers to give their products
shoutouts in their video you know how
nachos can own football game and soda
can own a halftime show that's how brand
deals work there is a ridiculous amount
of money in brand deals so much money
that even big-time traditional
celebrities like Snoop lion have gotten
in on the act
akkad Mike it's hot pocket like it's hot
in fact some youtubers can make as much
in one branded video as they do from an
entire month of normal ad revenue with
even more money coming in from simple
social media pushes $2,000 just for
hitting like on a video $5,000 for
tweeting about it you heard me one
measly tweet can buy you a jetski so you
know kind of makes sense that a lot of
youtubers aren't doing brand deals hey
drew is this a brand deal right now why
yes it is I knew it this video is being
brought to you by the good people at
grapevine who connect brands to online
creators that's right this video about
brand deals is itself a brand deal paid
for by a company that helps youtubers do
branding it's the inception of Brandon's
the final stage of making millions on
YouTube comes from being a famous person
studies have shown that American teens
rank the likes of Smosh fine brothers
and Ryan Higa above a listers such as
Jennifer Lawrence Harry Potter and
Leonardo DiCaprio damn they Oh can't win
anything after amassing millions of subs
YouTube celebrities like marble shane
dawson and her favorite insane swede
pewdiepie have essentially become the
wrong
as a celebrity all kinds of revenue
streams suddenly open up to your
merchandise both deals new video games
speaking engagements and TV shows here's
a little secret when you're a famous
person people basically just throw money
at you and all you have to do is stand
there and look pretty
come on I'm kind of a famous person ah
those are all quarters joke's on you I
gotta do laundry so now you're probably
like thanks for the finance lesson nerd
but how can I make some that sweet sweet
youtube deal myself I'm sorry for giving
you a terrible voice the answer is do it
a lot decide what kind of videos you
want to make preferably something you're
passionate about and what kind of
audience you want to reach then start
making them every day or as close to
that as you can eventually an audience
will find its way to you and once you
start to gain a bit of a following then
it's time to try to find a brand to
partner up with how do I find a brand to
partner up with us uh we didn't ask that
that's where grapevine comes in I knew
it grapevine is a service that connects
content creators with brands willing to
sponsor their videos and they even offer
a free calculator to see how much your
channel can make it's cool right wait
this videos brand deals for a company
that finds you brand deals yeah like I
said it's a video about brand deals that
is itself a brand deal paid for by a
company that does brand deals that's
like the inception of brand deals
already made that joke like five minutes
ago I was watching PewDiePie that's it
for this edition of hashtag news if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
comment with how much this video has
helped you get and load in please
subscribe by hitting the button below
we're doling out free financial tips
here so you kind of owe us one and don't
forget to check out the link in the
description for Grapevine will basically
make you rich at which point can I
borrow like twenty or thirty thousand
dollars seriously I need it I need it
now
I'm drew Coolidge or as millionaires on
YouTube would call me drew but I can do
this I can't I can't do this where's my
money huh seriously I need the money
just get famous yeah huh